stories are how we learn best we are
wired for story we're living in the
ultimate story we live in a big story
everything is about story people and
their attention span it's getting
shorter and shorter you've got to
capture them and I think if you provide
content where people can get the idea
digest it and act on it you will create
powerful content you have 26 books do
you wait for inspiration to hit you or
do you have any habits or routine so
that there's a level of consistency in
you coming up with strong ideas
so how do you create incredible engaging
content what are some of the Insider
secrets and content creation strategies
when it comes to the routines the habits
and even the Frameworks for consistently
putting out content that people love
well I'm excited because on today's
episode of the think media podcast my
guest is John Gordon now if you've never
met John before he is a best-selling
author of 26 different books his book
The Energy Bus has sold over two million
copies he been featured everywhere CNN
CNBC the T Today Show he's worked with
Southwest Airlines and the Miami Heat
and all kinds of different Fortune 500
companies who benefited from his
principles as an expert in
Communications and Leadership and
mindset in positivity and in so many
other topics we're going to really be
learning from him today about how we
could power up the content we are
creating right now on YouTube across
plat forms and maybe someday you dream
of writing a book or packaging what you
know into some type of a program John is
the expert and we're going to learn his
Secrets today John welcome to the show
Sean great to be with you so give us a
little backstory if people are just
meeting you you're incredibly prolific
how did this whole thing get started
with you publishing what you know
posting books publishing books and all
of uh your career what it's been up to
today you hearing you talk it's
interesting because you're going from
the lens of people are doing videos and
then one day maybe you'll write a book
for me it was about writing and sharing
what I wrote and now I'm moving more
towards videos and the video world and
so I always saw myself as a a writer
first and a speaker second but I have to
say I didn't even know I was a writer
until it hit me when I was asked what am
I Born to do why am I here what happened
was I was really struggling with fear
stress
anxiety I lost my job during the.com
crash all the way back in 2001 how will
I pay the bills how will I support my
family two little kids a wife a mortgage
and I was crumbling from the inside out
and I was blaming my wife Katherine for
why my life was falling apart and I was
blaming her for why I wasn't realizing
my dreams she had enough of my
negativity and she said you know what I
love you but I'm not going to spend my
life with someone who makes me so Miser
is you need to change and that began
this journey of of wanting to be a more
positive person so I remember saying
what am I Born to do why am I here and
why am I so miserable I realized I
wasn't living my purpose I asked what
that was and writing and speaking came
to me in that moment I'll never forget I
want to be a writer and speaker I'm
going to start doing this work to make
an impact so it started with I want to
add value but what will I write and
speak about well I want to be more
positive so I started to research all
the ways that I could be more positive
so think about that I'm curious I want
to be more positive I started reading
about positive psychology this was
during the emerging field of positive
psychology so no one really heard much
about it it was new it was exciting it
wasn't developed as a field but I was
taking some of the ideas and I was
practicing them seeing results so then I
started a weekly positive tip and every
week I would share a positive tip why to
add value value to share what I was
doing to make an impact because Sean I
realized I was I was miserable when I
focused on myself and that's part of why
I was crumbling in so many ways because
I was trying to be a success and then I
realized no it's about making a
difference adding value serving others
making an impact and once that became my
lens and my focus that's when I said how
can I add value so I was one of the
first Constant Contact email people
sending stuff out way back in 2002
started my weekly positive tip five
subscribers my mother my brother best
friend from college they were getting
that newsletter whether they liked it or
not but you know what people started
sharing it I would meet people get their
email add them to the list and then send
them next week's newsletter so I didn't
even know what I was doing I was just
doing it finding a way to collect emails
and then send them my work and people
started reading it sharing it next thing
you know someone came along and said hey
I love your newsletter you should write
a book and that began the process and
the journey of going okay now I'm going
to think about writing a book and that
began my career in terms of of being a
writer first and then I was told that if
I wanted to write books I needed to
speak because No One's Gonna want to
read your book if they don't see you
speak and it's hard to get your work out
there and no one's going to publish a
book unless you're speaking as well so I
was forced to actually go speak even
though I was terrified to do so it's so
powerful hearing your story and you know
I took away three C's of tips of content
creation just in the opening here you
know number one you were talking about
being curious I think that if we are
lacking inspiration in our content
creation if we stay curious we're
reading we're studying and then number
two you are consistent and you committed
to this weekly positive tip and I'm sure
in the process of doing that it held you
accountable made you
accountable to readers even though it
started small you were consistent number
three you then began to build a
community but focused on a community you
said how can I add value to others as
opposed to thinking about yourself
what's in it for the viewer what's in it
for the reader and then bonus tip
Constant Contact which would be why it's
so important to build an email list and
I think for every YouTube Creator a lot
of times they don't think about that but
you know of course you can use other
things like aweber or all these
different software Constant Contact is
one of them but to me how are you going
to capture the audience that engages
with your work even Beyond subscribers
and then eventually getting on uh stages
which I think one of the opportunities
for everybody you know listening to this
today is the world's kind of changed you
no longer have to necessarily travel or
get on a plane to get on a stage because
you could get on a podcast like this or
you could build your own platform and
get on YouTube and that could be a great
way to get the message out about your
books and your content but you know as
we are um jumping into this why do you
use social media in video now yeah so
for me if I if I go backwards if I go
backwards in the past it was about
putting out content trying to add value
trying to write and share what I was
doing and what I was thinking I had no
idea that that newsletter would be the
most valuable thing I ever did from a
business standpoint I was just trying to
add value and yet as people shared it I
then got invited to speak and now what I
realize is most of my ideas for books
came from a newsletter I wrote or an
idea I wrote you go went back to being
consistent I was being consistent and
writing every week that newsletter guess
what it's
2023 I started that in 2002 I'm still
doing the newsletter
every single week and we have a lot more
subscribers a few hundred thou like four
500,000 now people say I should be in
the million I probably should I didn't
focus enough on just driving driving
driving the newsletter we're actually
doing that now but the good news is it's
very organic like those who are engaged
with my newsletter are very loyal they
buy the books they're always consuming
the content they come to our leadership
trainings now it's led to everything
that I do and here's the thing when you
do write a book or you do have a product
most people will buy from a direct email
more than they will off of social media
so I'm sure you have research on that
and you understand that right Sean like
direct email is still the king in terms
of getting a response and this
newsletter list of engage people is is
key why am I moving towards social media
and media now for me it's just another
channel it's another way to to reach
people to add value to provide content
to expand the audience to have more
influence and reach more people I wish I
had a bigger YouTube presence I don't
it's something I need to invest more in
I need to listen to you more I have your
book right here actually so I need to do
more of that but we are moving in that
direction I've been investing a lot in
Instagram and Twitter's always been a
big following of mine and to me it's
just what medium can I use to reach more
people to have more impact but still
even now I'm still more than ever now as
I'm setting stuff out I'm also saying
sign up for my free newsletter or
providing a lead genen that will get
people to then be engaged with my
newsletter so now I continue to build
that Community because that's the
greatest thing we can do as we move
forward so I love media I'm getting
better at it especially from the video
portion I've done TV over the years a
lot and I know it's a it's a powerful
way to to to reach people and to impact
people and to move people but as a
writer I know that my greatest gift is
in the books that I can actually put in
someone's hand or they can buy and they
can then read and it can impact their
life so I see media as a way to connect
with people so that they'll read the
book because so often the talk alone
doesn't do it but when you read
something it becomes something you
internalize and then it becomes a part
of you I am who I am in so many ways
because of the books that I've read and
the people I've met along the way and
talks are motivational talks are great
you can hear a talk it could it can
impact your life but I think more people
get impacted by the books they read so
powerful and kind of shifting into
content creation itself and I do think
it's okay to maybe pull out a little
abstractly whether it's going to be a
video whether it's going to be a book of
course there's something much more
profound and researched and deep about
putting a book out there but when we
distill it down whether it's metaphors
analogies frame Frameworks you've been
so prolific in coming up with strong
content and everybody listening to this
wants to stand out from the crowd they
want UniQue Ideas they want to come up
with something strong they want to um
illustrate points with story what are
some of your tips especially having
written 26 books you've got a brand new
book as well the one truth and we'll
talk about that a little bit later but
you've written you've come up with these
powerful and poignant illustrations I
think the Coffee Bean book is one of my
favorite books and and once once I
started to think about that illustration
I can never think about coffee the same
let alone my attitude the same um and
things like that so what are some of
your tips for somebody that wants to
have more powerful ideas come up with
you know stronger content overall I want
to invite you guys to our YouTube 1K
challenge you can join this challenge
for free as we show you how to grow grow
your first 1,000 subscribers and make
your first $1,000 on YouTube we've had
countless people join us during this 1K
challenge who are now at 1,000
subscribers and past 1,000 subscribers
making money on YouTube and you could be
the next person if you just go to 21k
challenge.com you can sign up for the
very next challenge and we can't wait to
see you guys there we've heard the term
that a picture is worth a thousand words
and an analogy is worth a thousand
pictures and when you give an analogy it
helps people understand and make sense
of it and then understand how they can
implement it stories are how we learn
best we are wired for story we're living
in the ultimate story we live in a big
story everything is about story this is
why media creation is so important
you're telling a story through video or
you're telling a story through a book
you're telling a story through a podcast
whatever may be we're all telling
stories we learn best through stories
and also when I tell people about
speaking I always say start with the
principal share the principle what's the
story that brings the principal to life
and then how can they apply it how can
the audience apply it and then make it
applicable to them so when I'm speaking
to a different audience or I'm doing a
video if I'm speaking to athletes it's
going to be a different application than
if I speak to a company but the story
can be the same and the principle is the
same but how it applies to them is
different and so that's one of the ways
that I teach people people how to bring
principles to Life share the stories and
apply it but also as we're you know
creating content I think we're
ultimately trying to convey convince
share sell but we always do it through
story and we always remember the most
through story and what's the universal
experience how does it apply to the
audience how can they connect with what
you're saying and what does it mean to
them in their life if it's just about
your life and you tell a great story
about you that doesn't do a whole lot
unless they could actually see
themselves in the story and realize how
they could actually apply what they're
learning from the story and so I think
about I'm I'm a person of faith I think
about the Bible for instance it's been
around for thousands of years and it's a
series of stories that teach lessons and
convey spirit and messages and
principles and thousands of years later
people are still able to live their
lives by the truths that are shared but
I think we have that power and the
opportunity every day to actually do
that with fresh new content and bring to
life principles in a new and fresh way
it reminds me of something that even
Jesus said where describing him in the
New Testament it was saying he often or
the majority of time spoken Parables
right uh and illustrations of Truth and
so your framework is what's the
principle and I think this could be
applied of course in some videos in some
content you may want to teach three four
five 10 things that may be too many a
lot of times there's the opportunity of
maybe one video One principle one video
one big idea one video one thing that
you want the viewer to to learn so
you're saying principal then what's the
story that illustrates that I think
that's a big opportunity for us somebody
said once that facts tell but stories
sell and this idea of when you just hear
the principle you hear the information
you're like all right I think I get it
now the story brings it to life but then
that application number three is so
powerful because how does it actually
apply to the viewer the audience we
always say the Creator who understands
the viewer best wins and you really
brought Clarity there when you said if
you're talking to athletes it's going to
be different if you're talking to CEOs
or somebody in a company and so just
thinking about man who's watching or who
am I trying to reach and when you begin
to articulate with empathy the
contextualization of that principle to
the single mom with a couple kids trying
to do a side hustle versus the
professional on a commute that is on
their way to a corporate job man it's so
powerful on how we could really level up
our content in your process how do you
come up with a brand new big idea you
have 26 books do you wait for
inspiration to hit you or do you have
any habits or routines so that there's a
level of consistency in you coming up
with strong ideas so Sean it's actually
28 books so now so not 26 it's 28
updated bio I got you 28 and and
Counting where I got updated bio yeah my
friends always joke hey we just had a
conversation with John he just wrote
another book I basically think in terms
of books I think in terms of that would
be a great book that would be a great
topic when I talk to someone we have a
conversation I'm like you should write a
book about this this and this and
they're like oh what a great idea I was
with Tim TBO the other day and I'm like
Tim that is a book right there like I
saw it so clearly that should be be a
book some people take me up on it and
say you're right I'll do it other people
say yeah yeah maybe so I think in terms
of that so as I'm living my life I have
my eyes open I have my ears open and I'm
basically tuning in and I'm always open
to what is being said what I'm hearing
and I get these hits I get these just
knowings that oh that's a book when I
wrote The Coffee Bean with Damon West
dbos Sweeney was telling me about it at
Clemson Damon had just spoke to Clemson
about the Coffee Bean dab was reenacting
Damon's talk which is very funny that he
was doing that for me and as I'm
listening I said that's a book I had the
visual of it and the vision right away
and I knew what it should be so I
basically am open I'm listening I'm
hearing I'm curious and I'm always
thinking oh that's a great analogy oh
that's that's a great metaphor oh that's
a great illustration I should write that
I should share that and when it hits me
and I can't let go of it when it's
something that's seeping into my soul
and it just won't leave me alone I know
I'm supposed to write that book when I
start talking about it and start sharing
it with others and then I see how those
principles and those lessons start to
impact people I'm like okay this needs
to be a book and now I'm doing the same
with videos as I'm living life and I I
hear a phrase or a thought or I think
about what someone needs to hear about a
certain topic that is now something that
I'll I'll write down I'm now keeping a
list of of various ideas I think people
should have a notebook or on their phone
where they're keeping ideas of
inspiration and things they want to talk
about if you don't write it down when it
comes so often we forget and it's gone
and you'll never get it back so when the
inspiration hits you got to write it
down and you have to be open and willing
to what's coming your way we are
conduits we are conductors I truly
believe that there's a creative force in
this world and when you connect to it
and you're open to it you become like
the antenna you become the conductor
that actually it moves through and then
from there it's coming to you and
through you for you to share with others
what's coming to you what are you open
to what's your gift what do you love
talking about what energizes you what
could you share that that other people
can share that will impact people what
can you talk about that other people
can't talk about in the way that you do
what's unique about you and as you start
being open to that and you start looking
for that inspiration and being open to
it and believe that if you're open to it
it will be found a lot of people say
well I'm not creative now you're just
not tuning into creative thoughts you're
not just being open to it we're all
creative we all we as my friend Iran
mcmanis says we were imagined to imagine
we are created to create and we are
meant to be creative and when we are
that's when we unleash the genius we're
meant to share in this world and I think
people need to say I'm open I'm willing
okay and then just find what inspires
you encourages you what does the world
need how can you serve the world and how
can you in your own unique way serve it
to others and I think that's something I
I do often it's like I walk every day
pretty much and I find that my daily
walks going back to consistency daily
walks every day of gratitude and then
prayer is where all the ideas from my
books have ultimately come from most
people get their ideas in the shower
mine are on these ideas on these walks
where the ideas just come and I'm like
boom I write it down and when the when
more and more of the book starts to
unfold or more and more of the ideas
start to come then I realize that's it
but you nailed it earlier a lot of
people when they start writing a book
they'll write five books in one they try
to put everything into one book no just
write one book One Core message when
you're doing a video as you said One
Core message message people and their
attention span that it's getting shorter
and shorter you've got to capture them
you got to have a have a big idea you
could have something they can take away
from that and I think if you provide
content where people can get the idea
digest it and act on it you will create
powerful content whe rather than saying
this video is gonna be 15 minutes long
it's G be all these ideas I think today
the more we can actually give people one
idea the better and that's why I say
okay that's not another that's not
that's not this book that's you know two
books from now the next book is the one
I'm going to write about this and I keep
my books very focused and with core
messages people read it then they read
the other because it's digestible it's
something they can read it's applicable
and they see the impact in their life
and I'm not putting too much into one
book so many Rich insights there that we
can apply to the content we're creating
I want to shift to kind of the second
part of our conversation in a second
especially with you being an expert on
positive psychology and knowing that a
lot of us are dealing with all kinds of
challenges and it's it's hard to stay
positive and stay consistent and
overcome discouragement but I do want to
ask you a question for everybody
listening a lot of our community is
either they're they're creators on
YouTube so they're trying to make a
living as a content creator which is a
whole movement right now the Creator
economy and the fact we can turn our
passion into profit and then there's
many entrepreneurs leveraging YouTube
for leads customers and sales
um and understanding the power of
building their personal brand on YouTube
and so I'm curious as an author that has
been incredibly successful speaking
right now into
2023 do you think it's an opportunity
and would you recommend that the
listeners to the think media podcast
consider writing a book do you think
that would be a worth while investment
of their time and
energy in a world where it would seem
that like let's do a podcast let's do a
video any any thoughts for the
entrepreneur for the content creator on
on should they consider writing a book I
believe the book today is basically your
business card of of yester year so when
you have a book that is your business
card you hand it to someone it gives you
a position of authority it gives you a a
position of of of Excellence it gives
you a position of of someone who has
knowledge and wisdom on a particular
subject and it elates you and your stand
Now videos are Awesome YouTube is
amazing people have bigger Brands than
me that are on YouTube and yet I get
paid
$75,000 a talk because I wrote books and
because I'm seen as a thought leader and
an expert in my field and so you could
write a book that makes you an expert
and that elevates what you can command
as a speaker as a consultant just as
someone who is a again a position of of
authority so I think that's why a book
is is really important and helpful to do
that it separates you it causes you to
stand out and to this day for some
reason there's something about the
written book there's something about
holding a book that says here are my
thoughts here are my ideas I put them
into this this package that you can now
take with you and then when you read
that book or someone else reads it 10
years from now 15 years from now it's
like a time machine you're reading that
book that was written literally The
Energy Bus was written in 2006 it comes
out in 2007 the book comes out where
2023 wendam Clark read The Energy Bus
said it turned around his mindset helped
him with his positivity and he just won
a PGA Tour event he won $3.6 million he
read a book that I wrote in 2006 and it
helped him today with his life with his
career as a pro golfer because he was
struggling with negativity and as a
result of that he's now thriving that's
the cool thing about books is that again
it's it's it's Timeless and you're
writing words from where you are now
your spirit now and you're putting them
on paper and someone can read them at
any time so that's why I think people
should definitely consider writing a
book and I always say pick the book and
write the book first that if you died if
you died this year what would you want
to leave behind what's a burning desire
a passionate message that you just have
to share that you want to leave behind
if you should go and that should be your
first book and then you live this year
you want to write another one okay
what's that that next book but maybe you
don't want to write another one maybe
you just write one and that's the one
that you're meant to write and I believe
we all really do have a book within us
that we're meant to write and you just
have to find out what that book is for
you so I believe you do your video you
do your content and then you have a book
that sort of allows you to actually take
your thoughts into a printed form that
allows people to read them anywhere they
go and it's only going to just elevate
your brand John Gordon is the author of
28 books including 12 best sellers in
five children's books his brand new book
The One Truth is uh either coming soon
or it's out now and of course check out
all his social media platforms and his
links in the show notes of this episode
but we are doing this podcast it's two
parts so I want to make sure you're
subscribed rate and review this wherever
you are and listen to part two where he
is going to tackle destroying negativity
and bringing a whole another level of
positivity especially if you feel like
you're in a slump or slow growth or
experiencing some discouragement right
now with the growth of your business or
your YouTube channel